In our example, the dynamic slice simply excluded only 2 lines out of the program,
namely these 2 lines.
This may not sound like much in terms of reduction.
In a larger program, however, a dynamic slice can reduce
the number of statements to look at considerably.
First, they contain only executed lines.
That is, lines that are executed don't become part of the
dynamic slice in the first place.
And, of course, a line that's never executed can't have anything to do with a bug.
It may have something to do with a fix, though.
Second, they only contain statements that actually influence the output.
If your output contains several independent parts,
then a dynamic slice of just that part
will be much, much smaller than the entire program.
In 2010, we did a study on 7 bugs in Java programs
and measured how big their dynamic slices would be.
To start with, on average only 7.3% of the lines
were actually executed,
which means that a simple coverage tool
which tells you which statements are executed and which ones are not
will really focus the search to a very small part of the program.
When looking at the dynamic slice,
the reduction in size becomes even more apparent
because, again, on average the dynamic slice encompassed only 2.8%
of the lines in the program.
Since there are nice tools available
which compute dynamic slices automatically,
using such a tool in the first place will immediately tell you
which places of the program you can safely ignore
because they are not executed or because they cannot possibly have influenced
the output with respect to the bug.